I didn't get the job in some countries
no-one's ever had a job ah perspective
stop you participated in at rolling
cliche have some perspective by using
this attack of equivalency a wise and
sagely troll like you can look down from
on high in Nega way any discussion you
don't see as important think reality TVs
rotting our brains we'll don't forget
about starving children in Somalia did
you just say children in Somalia
well you shouldn't compare that to the
conflict in East Timor East Timor have
some perspective the Sun will someday
expand and engulf our entire planet well
this kind of logic is the perfect way to
ensure that we never talk about anything
ever again
which actually now that we're thinking
of it it's a great idea specifically as
it pertains to you you don't care about
these issues you care about being right
people are capable of being upset about
more than one thing at a time for
example the person you're watching right
now is upset about world hunger climate
change and the fact that your mother
gave birth to you
[Music]